now earlier today donald trump invoked
the fifth amendment while he sat for a
deposition in the new york attorney
general's sham civil probe it's not a
criminal probe into the president and
his family's businesses now remember it
was the new york ag leticia james
herself who actually campaigned on
prosecuting trump she said it often ask
yourself as you watch this does this
seem like somebody concerned with equal
justice under the law especially for
anybody named trump take a look
for attorney general because i will
never be afraid to challenge this
illegitimate president when our
fundamental rights are at stake i
believe that the president of these
united states can be indicted for
criminal offenses
that man in the white house
[Music]
who can't go a day
without threatening our fundamental
rights yes we need to focus on donald
trump and his abuses we need to follow
his money
we need to find out where he's laundered
money we need to find out whether or not
he's engaged in
here with reaction donald trump's new
york attorney alina is with us so you
you you have a candidate that ran on a
platform to destroy one man
in the state that she was going to be
the attorney general with all that power
this is a civil case
um
wouldn't this be and i i don't think the
president had any choice but to invoke
the fifth because if one comma if one
period if if we didn't if he didn't dot
every i cross every t wouldn't he be
facing a perjury trap in that
circumstance based on the
based on the fact that she ran a whole
campaign to take him down yes 100
percent sean you nailed it um the
reality of the situation is although we
hear that the d.a has dropped
effectively the criminal case
um there were also reports that the d.a
was waiting to see if he would testify
and if you know as he said if i said it
was sunny outside but there was an
overcast they would have come at me with
guns of blazing like they did on monday
with the nara investigation which he was
cooperating in unfortunately given
monday's incident
in tandem with everything else that this
man has endured and his family has
endured there's just absolutely no
choice in the matter we had to
tell him that this was in his best
interest and i quite honestly couldn't
trust the process
is there is there
has there ever been a time i i can't
think of one where somebody running for
a very powerful position attorney
general of a state i mean there's a lot
of power in that position where they
have run on a platform to take one
individual down i can't think of another
example no ethically you know the
attorney general is the highest law
enforcement agent in the state they are
supposed to be impartial and there is
not supposed to be any sort of influence
individually that would go into this and
remember everything that she said was
prior to her getting any testimony i
have to be honest with you sean and this
will shock viewers but she was quite
pleasant to be with today um i i did get
to actually meet and engage with her as
did former president trump um and it was
sad because in reality
posturing and politicking has become so
much of this country's dynamic that
people forgot to just be human beings
and today i saw a little bit of human
being in everybody in that room it was
quite pleasant but what we saw in the
videos that you've played that is
unfortunately what our country has
become which will lead us to become much
like a third country
third uh you know we're gonna be cuba if
we continue down this road people need
to remember to respect other people's
differences and to remember that
democracy the constitution these are the
bedrock of our country we are to respect
it and work within the bounds of the
legal system the legal system is there
it should work but you cannot exceed it
you cannot sit in her position and now
proceed to file a complaint because
after three years you must because you
have spent so many taxpayer dollars
what you're saying is pretty amazing
actually you remove politics from the
equation and wow they actually got along
today yeah we also kind of amazing we
all did quite honestly
yeah all right alina thank you for that
report tonight thank you we appreciate
it hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else